- I want to tell you a little something
about a time I had a real bad problem
and I didn't know how to fix it right.
The only time me and my
friends, we was hanging out
and stuff and we came up
on some drugs, you know,
like three kilos of cocaine.
And so, we knew that we
couldn't really profit
from it, serving it in our neighborhood,
so what we did is we shipped it a little
bit further out of town.
And while we was out
here, we'd get out there,
we got little change in our
pockets, so we buy weed.
Cause we, you know we get
high a little bit on the pot.
So we bought like a thousand
dollars worth of weed
and we got three spots going on,
one in the front, one in the
middle and one in the back.
And so we made sure to
always had weed and stuff
while we serving and stuff, you know,
and things going good, you know.
So my boy was like, man we've
been spending money with
all these dudes, right here
with the other apartment,
and, you know, they say they'll
look out for us, you know.
We still got some money
but we ain't got enough
to where we won't get a little issue.
So we figured that while we
been spending money with them,
you know, they will look
out, so we went over there,
we hollered, dude said, "Come back".
My brother-in-law, he was like
"Man, I think them niggas
is bullshitting man.
Them niggers ain't gonna give us nothing."
You know, so my brother-in-law
asked me he say, he say,
"Dawg when we get, when we
go on the spot, grab the gun
and we gonna go back over there,
and next time them niggas
die, like they ain't gonna
chip us off, we gon' rob they asses."
And I got a real bad
feeling about this one, man.
I just said, man, I really don't.
I was trying to tell him
my brother-in-law did
not even thinking about
even going back, man.
I couldn't come up with nothing right,
to where I can figure out how
to get some weed to the spot.
I started going over there and I couldn't.
And then having so, you know
we on our way back over here, man, dude
let us in and like, hold down right here.
I don't know how many people's
upstairs or nothing, man.
You know?
And I draw down on it, the living room
the one that, that left in
I draw down on and I told him,
man, you know, just chill.
You know, I won't do nothing
or shoot you and nothing dawg with you.
I had to do what I had to do.
I had to shoot you dawg.
And I don't, you know, I
don't know why they couldn't
talk my people's out of this shit.
But man, once it's in motion, man
you just gotta go with the flow, you know.
As bad as I didn't want to
man, you know, dudes start
crying and shit and you know,
told how many people's was upstairs, man.
You know, he said a couple
more peoples upstairs
and do nothing with his
brother or whatever.
So I'm getting ready to go upstairs,
cause I got the gun, I roll upstairs.
Dude upstairs, he got a gun.
I don't know he got a gun
cause when I go on the room,
I'm seeing him laying by the bro.
But all the time we got the
gun up under him and man
you talking about have a need ever studied
how to shoot a weapon.
I did not know how to shoot a weapon, man.
That nigger aimed that gun at me man,
I started busting, man.
I couldn't do nothing, but shoot back.
I'm running shooting, I'm
running away from him shooting.
And I hit the dude man and
knocked him to the floor.
You know, the girl in the room hollering.
But now like I say,
everything is in motion now.
So you know, we go in the
room, scoot dude off the bed.
That's a gang of money on under the bed
under the mattress and stuff.
And in the closet it got
like a big old trash bag
full of weed right here.
You know, I mean we got
pot, we got lot of weed.
I mean, I ain't never seen
this much weed, just personally
with my own eyes, unless
I saw it on TV, you know?
So we get the weed, asked
me how much money we got on.
I dunno how much money we got,
we got a lot of money too, man.
You know, I think that, you know,
when we came out here, out
there, we was going to try
and sell these two birds of
cocaine and buy some Cadillac's.
Shit, this enough money under the bed,
right here for a few Cadillac's.
We ain't got to think
about doing that no more.
So we just grabbed the
money and we got the weed.
Go downstairs we got dude downstairs
and I told homie, "What
you want me to do?"
You know, cause dude upstairs is shot man.
And we gotta leave.
He like he crying and shit.
So my dumb ass, I told
dude just going to leave,
get out of here.
I let him leave and we left.
So I go back, now we scared
now, I just shot somebody.
I ain't, nobody else did no
wrong, but me really, you know
they accessory to the crime,
but I'm the one, the main
my main piece to the puzzle right now.
So we in a spot, we serving a dope.
They come in the spot with a
shotgun, but you don't know
that he got a shot gun because
out here where I'm at a lot
of them dress, you know,
certain way when it's cold
he got a long trench coat on like this.
And I told homie that when
these motherfuckers be coming
in here like that dawg,
I wanna pat him down.
You know, man, you don't wanna do that.
Man, these motherfuckers be
carrying guns and stuff dawg.
You know, nigger ain't
gonna let no motherfuckers
come in this motherfucking spot dawg
and pull out no strap on you and stuff.
I'm patting you down,
if you don't want to be pat
down, don't hit the dope man.
Don't come knock on the door.
And that's how I found
out they had the shotgun.
You know, I patted him down at the door.
I said, dawg, you come
in here looking to smooth
with this trench coat on man.
So you gotta presume the position, man.
He say, what?
Nigger, you gotta hit the wall, nigger.
So I can pat you down, make
sure you ain't carrying nothing.
Sure enough, he had a shotgun on him.
And that's how I found out
they was coming in with these,
with these long coats they got,
they got dirty guns with them.
You can't let them in to trust them.
But anyway, as I did what
I did, so we serve it.
We out here doing good
right now, got a lot of weed
we like feel like we, the man.
Next minute, I know here come the police,
raiding all the spots.
So he did, I told green-eyed that,
I said dawg, they hitting
the spots, dawg, we gotta go.
We gotta get now because I
think dude, that got shot.
The brother told the police
that, people who did it
it's still in, it's still
in these apartments.
So they went door by door looking.
And we had to leave.
So me and my boy, we left, you know
we went out the back
way and got the train,
no, we got on the plane.
And came back here and so far, like I say
it's been going good, man.
You know, he's just thinking
about some of the shit
you did and you got away with it.
Man, can I tell you the dude lived or not?
I don't know, but if it was up to him,
he was trying to kill me.
Just like I just was just
I'm just busting the gun
just to get up out the room.
Cause I, when I came in the room
I thought he was in here
with just in and with
his bro and then a nigger
pulled out the gun and started.
He didn't even say nothing to me.
He just started busting.
And then I got scared and
I shot by fear, you know?
But when your life is on the line,
you got to do something that
that you wouldn't even think
you would do in order to live.
And that's what happened on my behalf.
I just was trying to live, man.
I get scared because
police had me stabbed.
No, I mean the police is
real crooked cops, man
you got some real crooked
motherfucking cops dawg.
That's when I tell you that you don't talk
you don't talk, if you
think it's cool enough
for you to slide through
them and do what you do.
They got people that have
walked right out of prison
and blow your door right to
the next side of the street.
So if you know what you
saying and you can handle it
then you do what you do.
Don't tell me about it.
Cause I don't need the
toughness to talk to me.
Share with the nigger
that you going to meet
down there on the dirt.
That's who you talk to about it.
I know because I seen people
that I know on the street.
That's been good dude.
And they walk right over
there and all the time they
being set up to be eliminated.
Say man, you know shit like that?
You'd be surprised to know
that inside the prison walls
there's certain games that
you got like Angola, BGF, UVN
CC riders, these all things
that's up on the paper.
And when they read the
certain papers that you read
there's codes that you follow
and you don't break them for nothing.
I don't give a shit how
you talk, how you said.
Cause when you break them, you fall.
I ain't no come back to talk about it
straight up it's over.
So if that's what you want to play at,
play it then.
I'm telling you some
life shit that I normally
wouldn't share with nobody.
But there are certain things
that they do in prison.
Same way with the Mexican Mafia.
When you got certain
dudes inside the prison
they'll sit back here.
The big shots for sit back here
and all the pawns will be up here
and the pawns will do
whatever needs to be done.
If they find out you are
head, head, top dog, man
they'll put you in lock
up and you will sit there.
And all the little pawns
that you have on this yard
he may go to lock up just
to bring you a clovo,
which is drugs and stuff like that.
Clovo is a drug.
You know, things that we have
on the yard or a wheeler,
a wheeler is a kite.
You bring that to the head man.
He passed on and they let
him know what's going on.
Who's doing what and so on and so on.
If they think that you're
doing too much on the yard
they send a motherfucker to come get you
and they get you up off that yard.
So it's a lot of things
that I can share with you
that you'd be surprised to
know that it actually happened.
And it goes down.
If they think that you need
to be really eliminated
they tell the police, look,
man, check this out, man.
We kinda have some business man, where
we need you kind of like step out.
You know like you didn't see nothing.
And the police will
turn their back and walk
to the walk through a
Sally port to look outside
while you in there stabbing
this motherfucker to death.
So when it's time to get
rid of you, you going
I don't give a fuck what you say.
You ain't going to get
away from the train.
You going, now if the heart don't stop.
I don't know, that's probably
God, I ain't challenging him.
I'm just telling you some real shit.
When it's time, when you up
against the big man and you
up against these dudes, that's
going to eliminate your ass.
Cause when you on the
street, you come the street,
when you come to jail dawg
and they show these mothers
they advertise these
motherfuckers that's faggots
or homosexuals, child
molesters, rapist and shit,
soon as you hit that line in there,
your ass is going to be broke off.
I promise you that, you can laugh your ass
home way from there.
What the police will do
though, to give you a way out.
They have a bail or something
sitting right here until
you tap on this motherfucking bail.
If you don't want to hit this
motherfucker in the yard man
and they'll tap on it.
You'd be surprised to see
motherfuckers that you thought
was some big tough dude walked
through here and you say,
God damn, did you see him hit that bail.
Damn look how big he is.
Motherfuckers don't, you
can't go in this motherfucker
trying to challenge these motherfuckers.
They take they man, they
take your booty man.
Don't tell me what you, what
you want, what won't happen.
They put a few motherfuckers on your ass
and strip your motherfucking
ass and take that ass.
And you can't do a
motherfucking thing about it.
Don't tell me how tough you is nigger.
You get a motherfucking knife.
Motherfuckers ain't
worried about you getting a
motherfucking knife nigger.
That shit is nothing in the penitentiary.
They all got knives and you, the tough guy
bring your ass to the yard.
Come on out here, check it out.
That's when it really get
funky, you know, all that talky
talk shit, that shit is bullshit.
That's that's the back
door yo talk right there.
The tough talk is when you come
out this front door, come out sick.
He had faced these motherfucking dudes.
That's waiting on you, man.
You know?
So I been there man, and I learned how to
stop running my mouth when
it's time to not run it.
And when it's time to get down,
don't ask questions
about it, just get down.
You know.
So I may, I had mother
used me one time, more
in the penitentiary he told me,
he say, man, I got the weed.
I got 300 from your peoples.
And I'm gonna take care of the money.
I'm gonna take care of the dope.
So the youngster come
tell me, he say hey SB
this motherfucker told
me you was doing the 300.
When I found out this
motherfucker did me like,
like I completely robbed him dawg.
And I swear to God, I
pulled a knife on that man.
Dawg, if you ever disrespect
me on this yard, man.
And when you get that
motherfucking dope here, dawg
you bring that shit.
You check that shit in to me now.
And everything that comes up
under this motherfucker dude right here
dawg, come to me, nigger.
And I mean that if I get you side slipping
on anything or taking something
niger out of pot nigger,
I'm going to break your
bitch ass off nigger,
on this yard nigger and you
and your home boys can
bring it right now nigger.
I'll fuck you up first nigger.
And that's how I go, man.
When you tell a motherfucker something,
nigger you mean what you say.
And you say what you mean.
Cause if you ain't ready to bag of words
on me, don't express it.
Don't spray it on a motherfucker.
That's that coward shit
if you don't nigger.
And then you get your
ass off the line nigger.
I mean I made this nigger give me
everything that he had dawg.
And when this homie came
up with what's up SB,
Nigger, what's up nigger?
He said, "I wasn't, I was,
I was just trying to say,
you know can I just kick it with you
and join in with y'all?".
No, nigger ain't no kicking
it, joining in nigger.
But we cool though, I ain't
got nothing against you dawg.
It's your homeboy nigger,
you, you don't side slick
nothing with none of these
old fake ass niggers.
When you walk in the yard,
you walk that motherfucker
strong dawg, and ain't nobody
going to give you no bullshit
and you'll make it out of there.
You walk in that motherfucking weak though
and start accepting so
many rude ass motherfuckers
around you, then your punk
ass liable to be a bitch
when you walk out of there.
And I'm telling you some real
shit, fags walk together.
I don't mean anything against no fags
but I ain't into that circle.
We don't fuck with it like that.
If you cross the bridge,
they going to break you off
for even fucking up because you were part
of a gang and he's
supposed to stand strong.
That's me.
I like to be strong.
And I like to stand on the front line,
not behind it, not on the
side of it, in the front of it
because I like to lead the right way.
I ain't going to mislead you,
but I'm gonna make god damn
sure that we make it outta here.
If you want to do them,
go out the other way,
go fuck with dude over there.
You won't make it out of the
legit way and keep your name
good, walk with me.
I'm old gang member
dawg, that actually still
think I have a lot of
activities inside me.
A lot of functioning that
should have passed on,
but by me being in jail for so long
and I'll come out here and I'm dealing
with a lot of these little
young niggers around
that's hard for me to even
smile at a little youngster.
You know, cause I'll
never want a youngster to
get the wrong impression.
There's one little nigger
up, down the street
hollering at me.
He's like "What's up, OG?"
I'm like "What's up?"
He like, "What's up, OG?"
What's up?
I was like, check this out nigger.
You know who the fuck
you talking to home boy?
Cause you keep asking me the same
motherfucking things home boy.
And you really don't even know
who the fuck your talking to.
I'm only asking you that
because you really need
to take a time out nigger.
And actually you're other
homie's who I am nigger,
for your mess, mess your day off nigger.
Cause I ain't gonna play with you.
He said, "Man, I ain't like that OG".
I said, "Nigger, stop calling
me OG nigger, I don't even
know who the fuck you are".
"Nigger my name is SB nigger
and I'm one of a motherfucking
kind home boy, so stop
getting at me nigger before
I break you off nigger and I'll beat
your ass out here nigger".
"I will beat the fuck out of you nigger".
"I will make god damn
sure that you don't wander
these streets no more,
you better know who the
fuck you talking to then"
Man, I didn't mean to
piss off OG like that.
But nigger you didn't piss me off,
you should've took your punk over there
and exercise your words
before you bring your back
up, before you came
over here to talk to me.
I don't even know the
you fuck you is home boy.
You know, so some of them
take it the wrong way
but you got to be tough on
these niggers out here, dawg.
You gotta be tough on
these youngsters too.
If you allow these
motherfuckers to slide with
with any type of slick word up on you
I guarantee you gonna keep on doing it.
But if you don't let
him slide one time you
ain't got to worry about the second time.
I don't fuck around with it.
My tolerance is no tolerance at all.
If I didn't invite you over,
then don't bring your ass over here.
I don't know you, don't want to know you
and I ain't asking to get to know you.
So we both gonna have a
good understanding nigger.
If you come to shop, then
let me know you shop.
Other than that, keep
your ass pushing nigger.
Don't choke up on nothing you
say with these dudes, man.
I promise you, you'll survive out here.
I god damn know, I for sure do know that.
I would fall a few people down
and most of the niggers out
of fall of beat their motherfucking ass.
This one dude that kind of got
a lucky little blow over it
because I thought he was
allowing me to shake me
shake his hand, he stole on me.
We got to fight, but I didn't get,
I didn't get the better end
because the nigger took off on me.
You know, I'm 100% man, man.
And I guarantee you anybody that fuck
with me, I ain't never crossed 'em,
I never back stabbed them or nothing man,
I'm a strong motherfucker all the way.
100%, man.
And this is by nature, not by choice.
I don't choose to do violence like that.
It came to me, it was
already birthed in me.
So this guy has some dog
food, some dog food stolen.
I say, well, first of all,
"Dawg, I'm not into that".
But at the same time he
said, "But no, you know
you have some sen, you
have a lot of seniority, a
lot of say so with some of these niggers".
I say, "Well, check it out dawg".
"I'm gonna say it to you like this homie".
"I really don't give a fuck
about no dog food homie".
"I don't, I swear to God dawg,
you addressing something to me,
that's way beyond my league dawg".
"Now I have a homeboy
that's under me, homie
that you can take that shit too".
"And if he can't handle a nig,
nigger, I'll come in then".
"But right now dawg, don't
address none of that shit to me".
"Cause I'm not taking no dog
food, nigger I kidnapped the
nigger a few days ago nigger
and he begged me to let his
punk out the car nigger,
so don't tell me nothing".
"I don't play games, dawg".
"I don't fuck with the the
kids shit out here homie".
"I'm telling you straight up, you take it
to my home boy dawg and let
him hear what you got to say".
" And if he don't resolve it
and then nigger then
you come to me nigger?"
"But don't come to me first home boy".
"Cause I don't fuck with
dogs or food like that".
"That ain't my, that
ain't my spiel homie".
Now at the same time he said,
"Yo homie, I don't mean no
disrespect to you".
I didn't take it out of
the disrespect, nigger.
I just told you to don't call
at me about somebody
else's dog food nigger.
I don't walk down the street
nigger watching if a nigger
boosts some damn dog food nigger.
So, he like, "All right
SB man, I apologize".
"Don't apologize to me because
we have no bad understanding,
I just want you to know you take it
to the guys up under me
before you bring it to me".
I'm older, I'm the top dog
nigger and I'm the real,
I'm the real McCoy homie.
Down there there's the
dudes that still developing.
So check them out first
and they'll let me know
if they can handle it
and I'll come to you.
Till then dawg, we ain't
got nothing else to say.
I'd get a moving.